when it comes to horror movies you need
a great ending to truly make it epic a
bad ending can ruin even the scariest of
spooky films but a great horror movie
ending can stick with you long after
you've left the theaters here are some
truly epic horror movie endings spoilers
ahead kill list this story follows two
hitmen J and gal who are hired to murder
three seemingly random people ultimately
their kill list leads them into the
English countryside where they're
attacked by a creepy cult gal is
murdered and Jay is forced to battle
against the hooded hunchback man Jay
dispatches his opponent with relative
ease with several stabs to its back but
he's shocked when the cloak is pulled
back to reveal his wife were still the
hunchbacks bump is actually their young
son strapped to his mum's back as part
of an occult ritual absolutely stunned
that he's just butchered his family Jay
disappears into his own mind as the
cultists applaud the fight and place a
crown atop his head the guest the chaos
begins when Army veteran David visits
the family of a fallen comrade at first
David seems like a cool guy but under
that charming hunky exterior there's an
ultra aggressive super soldier waiting
to explode
several plot turns later David is
chasing our sibling heroes Anna and Luke
through a high school haunted house
seemingly intent on doing away with them
luckily Luke gets the upper hand when he
stabs David in the chest the authorities
soon arrive on scene and it looks like
Anna and Luke are finally safe until a
familiar looking fireman walks out of
the gym the invitation the story of this
creepy film focuses on a man named Will
who receives a dinner invitation from
his ex-wife Eden for a dinner party with
some old friends that he hasn't seen in
years
but beneath the polite conversation
Wilkin sense there's something strange
going on all while Eden and her new
husband David are promoting some bizarre
cult as the evening wears on we'll
notices David walking into the backyard
and lighting a Red Lantern soon after
Eden and David start butchering every
guest they can get their hands on
fortunately we'll survives the assaults
but as he steps outside he sees
something almost as horrifying nearly
every house he can see is showing the
same red lantern that David lit earlier
implying that his dinner party wasn't
the only one to have such a violent
dessert
Krampus fed up and frustrated with his
unruly relatives a young boy named Max
loses the Christmas spirit tears up his
letter to Santa and tosses the shreds
out the window little does max know he's
just summoned a horned beast named
Krampus who plans on punishing Max's
entire family
but after a heart-to-heart with the
Christmas demon max wakes up to find the
whole invasion was just a dream and soon
he's peacefully celebrating Christmas
with his entire family
however max finds a bell with the word
Krampus edged on to the side as his
family also seems to remember the
horrible events of what max had thought
was just some Christmas evening
nightmares in fact it doesn't seem like
the family really escaped Krampus is
rough at all the witch in the witch
William and his Puritan family are
banished to the wilderness because of
their super extreme beliefs and forced
to contend with the supernatural monster
that seems to be skulking around their
new home the witch does a pretty good
job of tearing the family apart and
eventually the only member who isn't
dead or missing is eldest daughter
Thomasin left all alone in the middle of
nowhere and feeling cut off from the
Almighty Thomasin strikes a deal with
Satan yes following Satan's orders
Thomasin strips nude and wanders into
the woods where a coven of witches rise
into the air as Thomasin joins them
shaun of the dead this horror comedy
isn't just full of laughs it also has
some genuinely terrifying moments and a
few scenes that will leave you a bit
emotionally raw - honestly shaun of the
dead climax seems like one of the
darkest moments edgar wright has ever
directed as shawn says goodbye to his
best friend
edy who's been bitten by a zombie were
you talking about
only OG back you put
but in the last scene of the film right
sends the audience off with a bit of the
old switcheroo as it turns out Sean's
life after the zombie apocalypse really
isn't all that different from how it was
before the zombie apocalypse